et avant de voir précisément où en sont
les combats on va retrouver notre envoyé
spécial en Ukraine Julien chez Ida
bonjour Julien vous vous trouvez
actuellement à Vinicia à 300 km environ
au sud-ouest de Kiev vous avez ces
derniers jours en traverser beaucoup de
villes de village et vous constatez
toujours la même chose Julien un énorme
élan de solidarité
vous pouvez le voir encore derrière moi
avec ses dizaines de personnes à
l'extérieur d'un centre de la ville qui
sont en train d'empacter des bouteilles
d'eau par centaines par milliers j'ai
envie de vous dire de la nourriture
énormément de nourriture qui vont être
destinés à Kef surtout parce que Kiev
manque de tout manque d'électricité
manque d'eau manque énormément de
nourriture vous l'aviez déjà dit dans
nos précédentes éditions et en fait les
gens ici veulent que les gens de qui
elles puissent tenir le siège de la
ville qui n'a pas encore débuté mais
même ils ont des échos de d'amis de
proche qui vivent dans la capitale ou
qui essaie de survivre dans des bunkers
et ici c'était long de solidarité il
s'est formé très très vite avec le
besoin d'aider l'envie d'aider et
surtout l'envie d'aider les gens à
surmonter cette épreuve qu'ils vivent
maintenant depuis une semaine à
l'intérieur on peut pas vous montrer
parce que c'est une véritable
fourmilière et il aurait été trop
difficile de mettre notre caméra parce
que c'est il y a tellement de monde et
tellement d'agitation et tellement de
ferveur que qu'il aurait je ne peux que
vous décrire ce qu'on a vu c'est des
gens qui font des cartons qui courent
dans tous les sens on a même vu des
femmes faire des des des tenues de
camouflage avec tout ce qu'elle pouvait
trouver sous la main des boudrido des
bouts de tissus des chutes des tenues de
camouflage dessiner au soldats qui sont
sur le front et aussi des tenues de
camouflage destinés aux équipements
militaires
qui sont là-bas donc vous voyez il y a
tout type de solidarité qui s'est mis en
place tout cela quand même je dois vous
le dire dans un climat de suspicion
puisque effectivement nous avons visité
beaucoup de vide en Ukraine d'est en
ouest et ici c'est peut-être la première
fois depuis que nous traversons
l'Ukraine que nous avons connu un tel
climat de suspicion il y a presque un
réel climat de paranoïa puisque il y
aurait encore une fois des rumeurs de
présence de sabotorus dans la ville ou
dans ses environs vous savez ces
personnes qui sont censées marquer des
bâtiments clés destinés à être visé
ensuite par l'armée russe et ici il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de militaires qui
rôdent et qui sont assez comment dire
c'est sur le qui-vive
votre périple suis celui des familles
qui ont pris la route de l'exil un
chemin long et extrêmement difficile et
émotionnellement bien sûr
oui alors difficile d'un sur un premier
plan parce que effectivement traverser
les graines d'est en ouest c'est
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres c'est
des jours et des jours de traverser
beaucoup de familles de quartier nous
savons nous ont alors nous avons nous
avons croisé beaucoup de familles de
carquif
excusez-moi nous avons croisé beaucoup
de familles de Cardiff et de d'autres
villes de l'Ukraine qui avait été qui
sont actuellement assiéger des familles
qui n'ont pas eu le temps de prendre
grand-chose famille avec enfants
évidemment qui tente de prendre la
direction de l'ouest soit pour rester en
Ukraine du côté de vive mais beaucoup
tentent de passer les frontières
européennes notamment la Pologne avec ce
qui les attend là-bas et bien c'est un
second déchirement puisque les hommes de
18 à 55 ans ne peuvent pas le quitter le
pays suite à la mobilisation générale
décrété par le président ski donc ce qui
les attend nous avons-elle dit c'est que
oui les familles seront mises en
sécurité en union dans l'Union
européenne mais les hommes devraient
rester et ils s'attendent là-bas à un
second déchirement merci beaucoup Julien
chez Ida pour pour toutes ces
informations